bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouvel
épisode de sociologique dans lequel nous
allons parler de star wars
que la force soit avec vous alors on ne
parlera pas de tout l'univers de star
wars qui est bien trop large pour être
traité en une seule vidéo et on voit au
contraire se concentrer sur une période
très particulière de cette saga la
guerre des clones
c'est la guerre des clones oui bon
peut-être nous allons donc nous
intéresser à la série clone wars qui si
elle ne fait pas partie de la saga
originelle présente néanmoins un
avantage de développer les personnages
qui vont nous intéresser aujourd'hui
entre parenthèses cette série a
notamment l'avantagé d'introduire le
personnage d'ahsoka tano une jeune
togruta qui deviendra la padawan
d'anakin skywalker et qui est rapidement
devenu un de mes personnages préférés de
la saga et au pas de ça ici un à travers
les clones la question que nous allons
pouvoir nous poser c'est celle de
l'individu dans le précédent épisode de
sociologique je terminais mon
argumentation sur la socialisation comme
cela nous restons le produit de la
société qui nous a créés et cela pose
alors la question de l'existence voire
de la liberté de l'individu
si nous ne sommes que le résultat de la
société que reste-t-il de notre
individualité ou de notre libre arbitre
dans matrix 2 on peut d'ailleurs
remarquer que la conversion des
individus un même mode de pensée se fait
par la transformation physique de ces
individus ont l'agent smith
l'instauration d'une pensée unique se
retrouvent donc représentés par des
clones al'inverse dans star wars le
traitement des fans est bien différent
puisqu'ils ont chacun une identité
propre on peut même en reconnaître
immédiatement certains comme rex et cody
les lieutenante d'anakin skywalker et là
où ian kennedy
pourtant on pourrait s'attendre à ce que
des clones qui sont tous issus du même
individu et tous la même personnalité
à cela s'ajoute le fait qu'ils ont tous
reçu la même éducation et qu'ils ont été
élevés dans un complexe militaire qui
est le lieu par excellence où se
définissent des règles strictes et très
hiérarchique de vie sociale les
questions que nous pourrons nous poser
seront donc déjà bête qu'est ce qu'un
individu
quels sont les liens entre l'individu et
la société l'individu est il soluble
dans la société ou bien le continue-t-il
d'exister avec où malgré elle eh ben
c'est parti
beaucoup de questions ici pour être un
petit peu près 6 ou ce dont nous parlons
nous allons commencer par étudier
comment nous sont présentés les clones
dans star wars pour essayer d'en tirer
les premières conclusions sur l'art et a
fait le coup ne le fait pas il n'ya pas
d'essai ok allons-y dansant wars episode
ii l'attaqué des clones nous découvrons
pour la première fois l'existence des
soldats de la république lorsque obi wan
kenobi retrouve la planète kamino après
avoir traqué le chasseur de primes
responsable de l'attaqué contre la
sénatrice amidala et se fait donc
accueillir par les cabinets un débattre
cloneur particulièrement filiforme qui
leur font visiter leurs locaux le
premier ministre attend votre vie si je
vous en prie suivez-moi
nous nous attendions m odieux deuil il
s'aperçoit alors que les cabinets un
fabrique depuis plusieurs années une
armée de clones pour la république pour
commander par feu maître sipho dias
duquel on ne sait d'ailleurs pas grand
chose on apprend donc que les clubs sont
tous issus du génome du chasseur de
primes jango fett et qu'ils ont subi des
altérations en génétique pour être plus
docile et pour grandir plus rapidement
nos dols sont dotés des dépenses et
créative
vous constaterez qu'il est sont
immensément supérieur au droid
vous parliez de croissance accélérée oui
c'est essentiel sans cela il faudrait
toute une vie pour ramener un clown à
maturité maintenant il nous faut deux
fois moins de temps je vois ils sont
totalement soumis
ils obéissent à n'importe quel ordre
sans poser de questions nous avons
modifié leur structure génétique pour
les rendre moins indépendants que le
sujet d'origine bon dans les films c'est
vrai que les clubs sont surtout des
soldats qui font masse dans le fond ne
prend pas vraiment le temps de les
traiter comme les personnages à part
entière mais dans la série clone wars en
revanche ces personnages sont fortement
développées et on apprend beaucoup plus
sur leur identité
tout d'abord on remarque l'affirmation
de l'identité se fait par les
personnages eux mêmes ils adoptent des
coiffures des longueurs de baboo des
couleurs de cheveux différentes de façon
à bien se démarquer de leurs homologues
on voit à travers l'appropriation d'une
apparence commune une première forme de
l'affirmation d'une identité à travers
la série un autre élément constitutif de
l'identité d'un clown ça va être le fait
de choisir son nom alors qu'ils sont
originellement affublé d'un numéro de
série et l'importance de cet acte
taxinomique n'est jamais aussi bien
montrer qu'à travers un dialogue entre
un clown et android
la condition de ces t53 8,5 semble
s'être détériorée top
il s'appelle top ap c'est quoi ta top
c'est mon ami c'est pas un numéro 6 en
l'état on a tous des numéros mon numéro
et avis 3 4 5 2 à 1 8 9 6 2 4 6 4 9 8/7
de 1,3 4,7 son numéro et c'était 5,3 à
8,5
non il a un nom aucun claude n'utilise
le numéro se féminise et vous vous êtes
un numéro c'était 5 5 5 5
non je suis 5 à + - 5 mais s'inquiètent
un numéro je ne suis pas un numéro chez
un nom la différence est minime
pas pour moi ni pour aucun cru et c'est
là d'ailleurs intéressant de questionner
la notion d'individu chez les droïdes
qui est également loin d'être facile à
trancher dans star wars mais on va
éviter de trop s'éparpiller pour le
moment vous n'être qu'un droid ne savez
pas ce qu'est la responsabilité vous ne
savez pas ce que c'est qu'avoir un frère
je suis désolé j'ai toujours volé la
voir des sentiments humains mais je n'en
ai pas en fait il semble bien que les
clones sont des individus à part entière
avec des noms des comportements et des
attitudes variable d'un individu à
l'autre
loin de n'être qu'une reproduction à
l'identique la série nous présente des
lieux de socialisation comme des
tavernes que de réserver au clown qui
nous amène plutôt à les considérer comme
une communauté c'est à dire un ensemble
d'individus qui partagent de nombreux
points communs mais qui n'en reste pas
moins distinctes cependant il ya fort à
parier que ces différences ne sont pas
innés s'ils ont des comportements
différents
c'est sans doute qu'ils ont eu des
expériences de vie différente
une fois l'information finit lorsqu'ils
partent de camino leur expérience réelle
de la guerre les amène à se socialiser
de façon différente et donc à se
différencier
cette tension est particulièrement
visible dans un épisode où le commandant
rex et son équipe sont sauvés par une
famille dont le père se retrouve être un
ancien soldat clown ayant perdu toute
son unité ayant préféré déserter que de
reprendre part à l'absurdité de la
guerre pour laquelle il avait pourtant
été programmé depuis son plus jeune âge
et anik jean
mais je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
l'exemple des clones est intéressant à
étudier sociologiquement parlant ce que
le permettre de faire les clubs c'est
intéressant ici parce que c'est un
raisonnement sociologique qu'on ne peut
d'habitude jamais faire à l'échelle d'un
individu c'est ce qu'on appelle le
raisonnement toutes choses égales par
ailleurs une quêté riespach ibouth pour
les plus puissants d'entre vous le
raisonnement toutes choses égales par
ailleurs c'est un raisonnement que l'on
utilise quand on veut mesurer l'effet
spécifique car un point très particulier
du monde social pour ce faire on étudie
les effets de la variation de cet
élément en maintenant constante toutes
les autres variables du monde social bon
il est évident que ce raisonnement est
en fait assez fallacieux puisqu'il est
impossible de trouver 2
individus qui seraient égaux en tout
sauf en un élément c'est pour ça qu'on
ne peut utiliser ce raisonnement quand
statistique ou le fait qu'il est le très
nombreuses observations permet de
neutraliser cet effet et donc d'étudier
les choses toutes choses égales par
ailleurs
mais avec les clones on peut réellement
faire à petite échelle raisonnement
toutes choses égales par ailleurs
puisqu'ils ont la même identité
génétique et qu'ils ont reçu la même
éducation dans un complexe militaire
ce n'est que la socialisation après être
sorti de camino qui valait construire
comme individu donc nous pouvons étudier
la variation de l'expérience de guerre
chez chacun des clones bon ok mais cette
variation qu'en est il
malgré leurs années de service auprès
des différentes jedi les clones ont tout
de même exécuté l'ordre 66 faisant de
nous tous des lavettes pleurnicharde et
gémissante devant la mort de jedi
préféré au nom bayal assez courant c'est
ce qu'ont vrai qu'on pourrait être amené
à penser que les clones ne serait en
fait que des machines programmées pour
se réveiller un jour et exécuter les
ordres du futur empereur
cependant il faut bien se replacer dans
le contexte les clones sont aux ordres
de la république et non pas des jedi à
ce moment de l'histoire les jedi ont dit
des déclarés ennemis de la république et
de nombreuses personnes croit les
paroles de palpatine quand il prend le
pouvoir
ici c'est un à liberty
sous une prime était près 10 par la
suite de nombreux clones mon regretté
leurs gestes et certains se rallieront
même aux rebelles comme c'est le cas de
notre commandant rex que l'on retrouve
dans la série star wars readers avec un
petit coup de vieux quand même cette
façon on voit bien on pas l'expérience
de guerre participent au façonnement de
ces individus le parallèle peut
d'ailleurs être fait avec le nouveau
star wars qui décide pour la première
fois de faire d'un stand cooper un
personnage principal il s'agit bien sûr
plus d'un clown même si la question est
abordée dans le film au contraire on
apprend ainsi que les soldats sont
recrutés dès leur plus jeune âge est
conditionné pour devenir de parfaits
soldats nos jeunes sont ils à la hauteur
général je ne vous permets pas de
critiquer les méthodes
il semble plus doués pour la trahison le
grand souk devrait peut être avoir
recours à une armée de clones mes hommes
sont des machines de guerre programmée
depuis le berceau
alors il devrait pouvoir retrouver le
droid impact fine va donc devoir
s'extraire de cette socialisation très
violente où se trouvait une identité et
de la même façon que pour les clones on
retrouve l'importance de se trouver un
nom pour affirmer son individualité
montre ta pa lé fn battait à 87 f ois
seulement que j'analyse va-t-on trouver
un autre fn c'est sa fille tu t'appelles
ref id ouais
fidji des records se veut dire ça et
encore heureux qu'ils aient pas décidé
d'appeler fn
vous imaginez marine sur les jeannois
ceci est une blague qui insultent toute
la communauté des fans de star wars
ceci est une insulte à toute la
communauté des fans de star wars
qu'est ce qu'il fait en chaîne et tu
dois enchaîner jeumont du coup on en
revient à nos questions at on vraiment
une individualité propre ou la société
est-elle toute puissante dans le
façonnement des individus pour ça nous
allons étudier deux écoles de pensée
assez classique et qui permet de chacune
à leur façon d'éclairer un peu mieux ce
qu'est un individu au milieu de la
société alors premièrement nous allons
étudier la tradition aux listes qui
s'incarne en france dans la personnalité
d'emile durkheim dont on avait déjà un
petit peu parlé dans la première vidéo
le holisme c'est le fait de regarder la
société comme un ensemble comme un tout
cohérent et le principe du gaullisme
c'est de dire qu'on peut connaître un
individu en connaissant le système
duquel il n'est qu'une partie
on suppose que la société exerce une
contrainte sur l'individu qui doit
intérioriser et respecter les règles
principales turckheim cette notion de
contrainte elle est vraiment très
importante c'est vraiment la société qui
impose un individu des règles qui lui
sont extérieures dans les règles de la
méthode il écrit les faits sociaux
consiste en des manières d'agir de
penser et de sentir extérieur à
l'individu et qui sont doués d'un
pouvoir de coercition en vertu duquel il
s'impose à lui un fait social se
reconnaît au pouvoir de coercition
externes qu'ils exercent ou est
susceptible d'exercer sur les individus
pour dire km un individu peut donc se
comprendre en étudiant les structures
sociales qui ont fait naître certains
individus et ceux qui dévient du
comportement attendu de ces institutions
peuvent donc être qualifié de délinquant
de déviants ainsi le soldats clones qui
a quitté l'armée pour fonder une famille
ou films qui quittent le premier ordre
pour rejoindre la rébellion peuvent être
considérés comme des déviants et il est
d'ailleurs notable que c'est exactement
comme ça qu'ils sont prêtés par les
autres acteurs de ces institutions comme
des traîtres
prêtre mais je sais ce que vous allez me
dire en fait rien du tout parce que
c'est une vidéo
du coup dans cet exemple toutes les
personnes qui suivent à la lettre les
socialisation des institutions qui ne
sont ni des traîtres ni des déviants ont
aussi une individualité peut-il
nécessairement être d'evian pour faire
preuve de libre arbitre à l'individu qui
se croiraient libre et unique ne ferait
il que reproduire ce que le social lui
propose c'est ce qu'on pourrait penser
si on n'allait pas faire un tour du côté
des individualistes cette deuxième école
de pensée qui sera incarnée en europe à
travers la figure de max weber tellement
de choses à dire sur max weber que je
pense qu'on fera l'objet d' exprès pour
ça mais plus tard al'inverse de
turckheim weber voit l'homme comme un
être actif c'est lui qui façonnent la
société et non pas le contraire
si son appel une vision atomistique
chaque individu est un atom sociale et
il agit en fonction de motifs d'intérêt
ou d'émotions qui lui sont propres
en fait la vision de védas ce serait
presque dire que la société compte on la
comprend comme un tout cohérent
coercitive sur l'individu n'existe tout
simplement pas l'individu est sans cesse
soumis à plusieurs sphères de prise de
décisions qui ont chacune leur
importance dans son individualité les
différentes domaines d'action que sont
l'économie la politique l'art ou encore
la sexualité s'autonomise chacun à leur
façon et propose alors à l'individu des
systèmes de valeurs en taiwan east les
uns aux autres l'individu se retrouve à
leurs parties prenantes de situations
qui font appel à des systèmes de valeurs
qui sont contradictoires les uns avec
les autres
il ne peut donc pas exister sans
tensions internes et sans refoulement
d'une partie de son identité
le fait que ces systèmes soient
contradictoires force l'individu à être
actif et à ne pas faire que recevoir les
valeurs que le social lui inculque de
cette façon par la combi nation et par
la mise en corrélation des systèmes de
valeurs l'individu est bien un acteur du
monde social avec cette vision on
comprend mieux où peut se situer
l'autonomie où la liberté des clones
lorsqu'ils sont encore en formation sur
kamino il se confronte à un monde très
institutionnalisée et donc très cohérent
entre il n'y a aucune dissonance entre
les différentes règles qu'on va leur
enseigner c'est par la suite quand ils
vont se confronter au terrain et à la
réalité de la guerre il va se produire
ce qu'on appelle en sociologie des
dissonances cognitives
ces dissonances interviennent quand il
ya une absence de corrélation entre le
système de valeurs qu'on leur a inculqué
est ce qu'ils sont amenés à faire au
jour le jour sur le terrain
on remarque par exemple que c'est lors
de sa première mission que le film se
retrouve confronté à l'horrible réalité
de la guerre et que le système de
valeurs qu'ils avaient jusque-là
intériorisé commence à se fissurer
devant la violence réalité d'un massacre
en règle d'une population civile
l'individu n'est donc pas dépendants des
structures sociales puisque c'est lui
qui activement créer sa façon d'exister
dans le monde social mais
ces deux visions de l'individu peuvent
sembler à première vue irréconciliables
mais on ne peut en rester à une
opposition binaire parce que la
sociologie comme la force prend de
multiples formes si les classiques
d'opposer du recueil mais webber quand
on commence la sociologie leurs théories
sont loin d'être aussi tranchées et
l'opposition entre les deux est en fait
moins factuelle que purement didactique
dactique
paris en a qu'ont pas d'humour il faut
quand même voir que cette opposition de
pensée entre une vision partant de la
structure et une vision partant de
l'individu a été assez constitutifs de
la façon de penser la sociologie par la
suite en france par exemple cette
opposition s'est par la suite un carnet
dans l'opposition très forte qu'il ya eu
entre le sociologue pierre bourdieu et
le sociologue raymond boudon bourdieu ce
faisant le continuateur des thèses d'une
société structurantes qui détermine en
profondeur l'individu et boudon qui a
inventé le concept d'un individualisme
méthodologique et qui cherche à
comprendre les raisons personnelles qui
pousse les individus à faire certains
choix
bourdieu versus bouton le clash du
siècle ok ou quelques piques et
j'enchaîne comme je l'aï déjà souligné
ici simplifier au maximum les théories
de turckheim et de weber évidemment
durkheim avait lui aussi une pensée de
l'individu et webber avait lui aussi une
pensée des structures sociales on ne
peut pas les opposer comme ça comme je
lé fais de la même façon pour bourdieu
et pour boudon il était d'accord sur de
nombreux points même s'il y avait quand
même des désaccords irréductible entre
leurs deux façons de penser et de fait
dans notre quête de compréhension de
l'individu il ya fort à parier que son
aboutissement se trouve quelque part
entre ces deux extrêmes puisque nous
sommes finalement le résultat d'une
pluralité d'expérience et de
socialisation
la colère et un sentiment humain
je suis jedi voilà donc on finit sur des
notions qui sont peut-être un petit peu
complexe n'hésitez surtout pas à venir
dans les commentaires si vous trouvez
que je vais pas assez loin et que
j'explique pas assez longtemps certains
éléments après je précise que c'est très
difficile d'apporter une conclusion une
réponse définitive à ce genre de
questions puisque c'est des questions
qui restent toujours ouvertes et qui
sont toujours d'actualité
à ce propos c'est un thème qui se
rapproche pas mal d'une question qui
avait été posée au bac de philo l'année
dernière en 2015 l'intitulé c'était la
conscience de l'individu n'est tels que
le reflet de la société à laquelle il
appartient ça rejoint en partie
certaines questions qu'on a pu aborder
et le fait que la question se pose
encore montre bien que le sujet n'est
pas clos
en attendant je vous remercie de nous
avoir accompagné dans ce voyage
sociologie à tomber une petite seconde
je suis à vous qui m il lui tond
exécuter l'ordre 40 bien-être
abonnez-vous aux la chaîne sociologique
cette carte ou liste en dieu des rouges
des machines qui crée du marché qui
permet à ses côtés